great Gardens is like one of my all-time
favorite performances what you did I was
so scared I was sick oh my God I
literally people I like like I just I I
think I had some type of break psychotic
break you would like her yeah you would
have to yeah full commitment real weird
I I was just I didn't because I didn't
think I could do it you know have you
ever felt that way like it's all the
time I don't unpack for the first two
weeks of a shoot because I think I'm
gonna get fired
I'm always convinced seriously yeah
okay I'm like let me just not unpack
because it's so depressing to take
things out of the drawers like so and
then at a certain point I I feel like
they've filmed too much they can't go
back I'm not gonna get fired now